Salam alaikum warahmatullahi what I care
- how are you guys doing and this is a
short video hopefully which is meant to
elucidate our brothers and humanity from
the at midi community of course we
understand that the ahmadiyya community
is a small community of about ten
million people worldwide according to
statistics and then we also understand
that they because of that because of
that may be susceptible to kind of
violence or oppression all these things
Wow so the first thing we should
actually sell by saying is that whenever
you see people who who are susceptible
to those things we should be careful not
to twist you know ideological points of
contention theological points of
contention which I'm going to raise in
fact in this video to religious violence
or oppression or anything like that so
that's that's a disclaimer that I want
to make and just for those who don't
understand who and what the Atman is aa
the admin is are a group of people who
believe in the Quran the veracity of the
Quran and they actually even believe in
the son now the you know the the
literature of the Muslims of the Sunni
Muslims like Bukhari Muslim etc and what
they also believe which is what
separates them from the main body of
Sunni Islam and Shia Islam the fact that
there was a prophet that came after they
call him what I'm Ahmed now this man was
a man who was born 1835 and died in 1908
and was in British occupied India at
that time now I'm not gonna go to
conspiracy theories about him lazing and
conspiring with the British it of course
this is the main stream kind of
narrative within Sunni circles which is
that you know he was conspiring with a
British or he was enacting the British
will in that you know he kind of unquiet
eyes the the obligation of jihad
physical fighting back because the
British at that time they had an agenda
of course to to
do you militarize if you like the
aggressing military elements of the
indian colonial people's that's that's a
conspiracy i will call it or it could be
true
i'm not going into the details of this
now because it's not my area of interest
at this point in time but it's important
just to know what kind of narratives are
out there now here's what I do want to
say what you think is very important how
do we know a profit is a profit this is
a good question
okay how do we know a profit is a profit
now in the Islamic tradition I've
already made the argument that from a
completely textual basis that they
cannot be seen to be any profit that
comes after Prophet Muhammad why because
of the versions of lab where he's
referred to as hot and hot in the
beginning so that he's the scene of the
profits point is also the final prophet
now linguists and professor hoon
exegetes of the Quran through all of
history have said that this means that
he is the final prophet the Prophet
himself said in Buhari
in many different anyway I have in fact
different narrations that let it be
about me there's no prophet afternoon
now this is the strongest argument and
there are many arguments which are
subsidiary to those arguments we shall
meet to show that there cannot be a
prophet after prophet Muhammad from an
Islamic perspective however there's an
argument I want to make today which is a
different kind of argument you see well
I'm with himself who as we've said was
quite modern man in terms of his
political placement
he says the following he says that to
draw to judge my truthfulness or lies
there is no better test than prophesies
and he also said let it be known to the
unbelieving persons that my truthfulness
or false will be judged on my prophecies
there is no other touchstone for it and
of course I'm going to provide an
article with all of the references for
these things that he said so what he's
saying is and this is mentioned just
mentioned you know
in Boots where I will show you the
evidences for the references for those
particular quotations I just came as I'm
finding those quotations what I'm gonna
say is that I believe that what a madman
is actually right these points in fact
it is a good point to make that
prophecies are wise required for example
those two things to judge my
truthfulness of lives is no business and
prophecies is mentioned in a book called
rahani Mazzini the volume 19 page 288 is
also let it be known to the unbelieving
persons that my truthfulness or false
winters am uneasy there is no better
touchstone for it is in Amenas he mocked
he Islam page 208 of these references I
will provide in an article which I'm
basing it on this research on now having
said that he's saying basically my
prophecies which is my predictions of
the future this is the touchstone to
know if I'm truthful and I think this is
a very fair test because if someone is
being divinely inspired if someone is
being divinely inspired they should be
in fact yeah telling the truth about the
future because if God is all-knowing he
knows the future as well
very fair enough and that is actually
one of the challenges we as Muslims make
to non-muslims that if the Prophet had
made a prediction of the future that is
time-bound
for example place bound that ship have
materialized and if it can be falsified
this effectively falsify his prophethood
it's a very fair enough test because no
one knows the future for sure now I want
to just introduce you to two prophecies
or two or three prophecies that will I'm
adamant made and we want to look at
these prophecies and see was he telling
the truth or not he says what a madman
says in the following he says it was
revealed to me by the Most High God that
I should seek the hand of Ahmed begs
Eldar eldest daughter and to tell them
that a kindly treatment shall be dealt
to them if they accept the proposal and
that this marriage shall bring to them
blessings and blissful beatitude but if
they should refuse to do so the end of
the girl shall be very sad
and the man who shall marry her shall
die
within two and a half years and her
father within three years from the date
of marriage God the most high will
remove every obstacle in the end bring
her into marriage with me Tocqueville
Allah saying this yeah and turn the
irreligious people into Muslims and
bring to guidance those who have lost
the right path it's very clear what a
madman is saying that he will marry this
woman
whose name is Mohammad II Begum yeah
he's saying that will happen in this
time if this doesn't happen and so on
then we problematic now highs will jump
on this and say well hold on he says
that if the people repent there was a
condition of repentance the family if
the family doesn't repent then all these
things will happen however even after a
family was sending because they got a
little bit worried actually maybe this
guy is telling the truth the family side
writing you know letters of apology to
the two and so on even after that he
reiterated so a company because of
repentance he reiterated the same
message she said even after they
supposedly you know apologized and so on
but the death of Ahmed but beg broke
their backs and this was why they sent
letters of apology and regret so he's
acknowledging that they said assembly is
of a program as they were struck by fear
and terror in their hearts it was
essential that God the Most High
according to his ancient way postponed
the day of punishment to some later time
that is to the time when those people
again turned back fully to another time
of fearing and turning to God is
displayed as proved by the whole of the
Quran but the essence of the prophecy
that this woman will enter into this
marriage with me is an absolute fate
isn't a discovery is an absolute fate
which cannot be averted now this is
clear even after the so-called
repentance and apology so absolute faith
which were which one cannot be averted
he says so after these days when God the
most high sees that these people's
hearts have hardened and that they have
not valued the few days of respite and
relaxation given to them then he will
turn to the fulfillment of the prophecy
of his holy word
so you can't say that because of all the
family repented because here saying he's
definitely she's been definitely to be
married with me what did this happen
was he ever married to Mohamed he bigger
this is the question we have to ask
because this was saying it's absolute
the answer is no he never married her
and there's no evidence like he married
her in fact she got married to another
man now then all those bad things happen
to Mohammed he Begum did you know did
Allah break their backs and so on no
more so the question is how can his
prophecy be wrong if he knows the future
it seems someone may be a critical say
this man really wanted to get married to
this woman was using fear tactics to try
to persuade the woman for marriage but
that never materialized but
unfortunately what that did is it put
the cat in with the pigeons it put the
spanner in with the Woodworks because
now we can say that this is a false
prophecy which effectively you could
argue falsifies his whole claim to
profit so by the way he says this and
I'll give you the references in the
article you can check the other comfort
in the description box
by the way of prophecy the exalted God
revealed him to his number one that
ultimately the elder daughter of Mirza
Ahmed Beck son of menahalim Beck would
be married to me these people will
resort to great hostility and would put
many obstacles in the way but in the end
it would surely take place the exalted
God by all possible means bring her to
me
whether a virgin or a widow and would
remove all impediments and would of
necessity to the Sun and no one will be
able to prevent it yeah if this has been
in the hadith literature of the Salim
that he was saying that this is gonna
happen I'm gonna marry this woman and he
never did it imagine what the Orientals
would be doing they'll be having a field
day with this information now look at
this
in addition to this false prophecy yeah
secondary one he says it is God's
intention this is him again God's
intention that he will bring two ladies
in my wedlock
one will be a virgin and the other a
widow
therefore this inspiration now as
related to the version has been
fulfilled and presented by the grace of
God I have four sons from it this wife
I'm still waiting for the fulfillment of
the inspiration regarding Widow now the
thing is what I'm not married twice most
two versions he married twice before and
he married - harmik Bibi and no strategy
em bigger both of them yes both of them
are virgins now the question is he said
I'm gonna marry a virgin and the widow
so wait a minute we should do it the
other way Widow that he married well
someone can argue well when he married
her she was no longer a virgin okay well
this is the when she outlived him so she
became a widow but doesn't work like
that because he said he'll bring him -
no I - my wedlock eonni
that she was in that state of being a
widow already and then she was brought
to my weblog not that I made her the
widow or because of me she became a
widow Yani
so the two things here are interlinked
false prophecies relating to marriage
and so obviously someone will argue if
there was an oriental census
[Music]
self-serving prophesies because you want
to marry the Orient this will sell us
you want to hear the problem on tomorrow
and therefore you say you're gonna marry
this otherwise break your back to sand
that they would have a field day with
this and that he did not marry and so on
so forth by him
so imagine if it was us as the Sunni
Muslims will be here elated in front of
the international community with such
false prophecies
moreover well I'm Ahmed said I shall die
in Mecca or Medina and the man never
stepped foot in Mecca or Medina what
more do you want
ladies and gentlemen let's read the
whole thing are you taking out of
context
I don't think me brother because you
need you so this I shall die in Mecca
Medina means that before my death I
shall be bestowed victory like that of
madcap listen to this that I should say
that the holy prophet had vanquished his
enemies through them
sensation of majestic signs of Allah so
it will happen now the second meaning is
that before my death I shall bestow the
victory like that of Medina which means
that people's heart will be their own
inclined towards me the phrase God has
decreed I and my messengers shall
prevail points of victory like that was
Mecca and the phrase peace is the word
for my merciful look point to a picture
like that of Medina wait a minute
ten million people in the world which is
the side the size of London as a
religious community what Mecca Medina
I'm sorry to say how can you even
compare the victory of Muhammad's Allah
as something was stretched yeah from
Michelle a calamity never of Arabia from
the east part the worst is the worst
part of the West with such Yanni sorry
to say in significant gains
comparatively from a demographic
perspective of Allah but then those
don't forget hold on I told us the truth
so the Kakadu he spoke the truth
even though in many instances he did not
speak the truth - he said in so saying
he said to judge my truthful missile
lies there is no better test than
prophesies like we use the prophecies
and we come to the conclusion that
actually when you came to predicting the
future you did a miserable job you did
not do the right thing and therefore in
addition to all of those evidences that
point to the fact that problem house our
salah is the final messenger you also
have these clear evidences to the
brothers to the sisters in humanity
there are many brothers and sisters
which claim which clearly show
unequivocally ambiguously that Allah
Muhammad made false prophecies with this
legend gentlemen why I think we have to
be humble and I apologize if I came
across the lip of passion but it's very
important matter if we're gonna yeah me
leave a sort of album I'm going to leave
the bulk of the Muslim
body in their reasoning that remark
system is the final perfect the question
is there has to be some incredibly
strong evidences neither this man show
voilá moment that he had a revelation
from his own words or from the
information that is provided up on
Amazon
we invite the brothers and sisters in a
comedy sect to come to a mainstream
Islam and shot a lot to just go back to
what the Sahaba believed him
feminine women you meant to be for buddy
fellow into a loafer in them at home
Fisher Park if I say ik fecal mobilize
the Quran says if they believe in what
you guys believe in them they're on the
right path and if they go away from that
then they are in France question I just
say to the brothers let's go back to
what the Sahaba said on these matters
let's see what the morph SEO Hyun said
let's see what the exegete said for
hundreds of years was the Prophet
Mohammed the final prophet or not did
they understand it linguistically as
that I think you'll find that they did
please consider Sunni Islam Andrew oh
happy happy happy with open arms
well salam alikum warahmatu allahi learn
it